but let's talk about Deutsche Bank a bit
more I'm now joined by a professor hunts
Peter birkoff
professor of banking at the University
of horn and welcome to the studio
professor book of why should we be
worried about deutsche bank well it's by
far the largest bank in Germany and this
means in the largest European economy
it's a tool international bank so it's
much interlinked internationally so if
their troubles they're not only in
Germany all around the globe and that
means it's a very systemic bank the
bank's relatively new CEO John client
seems to enjoy some trust from from
shareholders he said to be the new broom
to clean everything up is he the right
man and what's his strategy well I think
he's much better than what we had before
at least if he's right man we see
afterwards for sure but he's not linked
with your old story of the deutsche bank
he's not linked with investment banking
with the old mistakes they've done and
so we might be able to enter into this
battle for a future for the Deutsche
Bank much more ruthless than the bumps
who have been inside and that's when he
says and the new broom he comes from
outside he's not like and mr. Jain
linked with the old investment bankers
and so he can be tough and as it's the
first thing in this our strategy must be
tough you must try to do things fast
this is not very nice it's not a very
nice strategy he's following because it
has to cut down size he's got to cut
down businesses which don't pay off and
he must get rid of people and it's never
a friendly job to do everybody seems to
be bashing investment banking investment
banking has made the bank billions over
the past 20 years now everybody wants to
get rid of it as quickly as possible do
you see the bank going back to the
boring and but stable Institute it used
to be first first I would ask did
investment bank really produce high
profits because much of the profits were
based seemingly on fraud some was just
zero gum some game between different
banks some of it is just profits today
and losses in the future and so much of
the problems today of the bank come from
the old investment bank
so I've doubt about that I hope the
Deutsche Bank will get become boring
again we visually shouldn't call it
boring we should call it reliable and
that's what client needs
I mean you don't have a bank which
changes every day and wants a lot of
money to earn as fast as possible with
you you want to have a banquet says okay
your perspective is thirty years so my
perspective is you thirty years and if
Bank become this it would be very nice
until here
thank you very much torture is by far
not the only bank in trouble around
Europe British banks have been hit hard
by the brexit vote to leave the EU and
now facing uncertain future Italian
banks are sitting on an enormous heap of
bad debt and because the banking system
is so incestuous many other lenders are
in trouble too so is there a new pan
European banking crisis in the making
here are some facts and figures for
months the brexit referendum campaign
kept Europe's financial markets in
suspense when the British did vote to
leave the EU the banks were the first to
feel the consequences stocks and British
banks crashed
trading in Barclays and RBS shares was
suspended briefly but UK banks aren't
the only ones in turmoil
this year deutsche bank share value has
plummeted from almost 30 billion euros
to just 16 billion Germany's biggest
financial institution has lost almost
half of its worth in Italy banco monte
de passkey has suffered staggering
losses and two-thirds of unique credits
value has been wiped off the books
shares in Greece's Piraeus Bank are
worth just half what they were at the
start of the year as our stocks in
Switzerland second largest bank credit
suisse these worrying figures show
europe's finance industry is anything
but healthy though the risks are
unequally distributed eurozone banks are
sitting on 900 billion euros in bad
loans a whopping song and Italian banks
hold more than a third of them
many firms could no longer operate
profitably in Italy a country plagued by
corruption and a poor business climate
the lesson Europe learned from the first
banking crisis was that risk should be
shouldered by investors but it looks
like it's taxpayers who'll be bailing
out Italy's financial institutions once
again this example from Germany shows
what that means the German central bank
estimates that since 2008 the cost of
rescuing German banks stands at 236
billion euros that's 3,000 euros for
every German taxpayer it was ultimately
taxpayers who bailed out the banks will
it be any different this time around if
we're looking at other European banks
and in particular if we're looking at
Italian banks that's not a pretty
picture is it not at all I mean if you
said before
deutsche bank is a potential problem
this is an actor problem you must solve
and it's several hundred billion euro
heavy so it's not like saving Greece
which is costly but can be done so we
must really find solution here there's a
big argument going on at the moment that
Italy wants to rescue its banks with
public money and that would contravene
EU rules why not let the Italians get on
with it and rescue their banks because
we have to guarantee the state that in
the end and the european central bank is
helping them to carry this heavy stated
and italy is among sticky countries on
earth with the highest level of stated
altogether so they have no reserves for
that so i mean we made this bet europe
in banking union under certain
conditions and now for in the first and
the first stress situation we forget
about all these conditions what does it
mean for Europe can be trust in anything
which happens in Europe if you just
follow this path on the other hand
what's the alternative a general banking
crisis in Italy might be very costly as
well and contagious
explain to me Mario Draghi's role in the
Italian banking drama that's very
difficult point I mean it's European
Central Bank which plays a central role
in financing Europeans the European
states especially Italy through low
interest rates he's responsible for this
development
because it's been head of the Bank of
Italy for many years before the crisis
and excuse me during the crisis so the
wrong incentives were led to these
problems now in Italian banks were set
while he was responsible as a banking
supervisor and other side ways to cover
up now somehow these things he's be done
he's been doing before the proper was
after 2008 when they had we had a big
crisis Italian economy did not recover
and the Italian banking system was
mainly used not to finance companies but
to finance the state and so the
companies did never really recover and
that's his period when he was in charge
in Italy so we're damned if we save them
and we're damned if we don't in fact
there's no real good way out of it so I
think we'll have a lot of well some this
some of is this tragic topic thank you
very much